This is unbelievable.
So I just learned that YFN
means your friendly neighborhood
hackers.
And look, we brought it with us.
Unbelievable.
This is making my day.
This is making my week.
This is incredible.
And really, I don't
know what to say.
This is amazing.
So whoever you are, thank you.
This is awesome.
So where's Laura?
So Laura, next year I think
we should give every student
one of these.
This will be in our--
so we've got some candy.
We've got T-shirts.
We'll get to those.
We've got welcome
to the last lecture.
Oh, there's some T-shirts.
We're going to let
TAs throw them out.
But you guys got a--
so we got a little bit
more to cover on diffusion.
I got a why this
matters, and then I
got a couple of things I want
to say, and then we'll conclude.
And like I said,
the plan today is
to conclude a little early
to give you time to fill out
the course evaluations.
We really take this seriously.
We really value any and
all input that you have.
And so please do.
If you haven't done it already,
please use the last 15 minutes
that we'll give you in the
class to fill those out.
It means a lot to us.
This is still-- it's
hitting me right here.
It's slowing me down.
I can do it.
I'm going to get through it.
So we were talking
about Fick's laws,
and you're only going to
be tested on the first one,
but I do want to tell
you about the second one.
You are not going to be
tested on the second one.
That is correct,
unlike last year.
Because we didn't have
time to get the lecture
in on the second law
before the recitation,
which was yesterday.
And so look, there will probably
will be a diffusion problem,
but not on the second law.
But still, I do want
to finish the example,
and I won't go
through it in detail,
but I want to set it
up and just show it
to so you have a sense of what
Fick's second law lets you do.
And we ended with the first
law, and I wrote the second line
down.
Now, the first law,
that is something I
want you to know about.
And so remember,
with the first law,
so let me go over here so you
have a whole board to use.
So in Fick's first law,
what that meant was
it's a law that describes
the steady state.
So Fick's first law
was steady state.
And this is now bringing back
memories from two days ago,
so steady state, which means
no time dependents, no time
dependents.
And so we had some
examples of that.
In the law itself--
I'll write it down here--
was that the flux is equal to
minus this diffusion constant
times the change
in concentration
over some distance.
And so we had this example
of a membrane right,
and so you could imagine
we had the glove.
It was the remember,
the butyl glove.
And so we had some distance.
Maybe this is like
a delta x, and there
was some concentration up here,
C1, and some concentration down
here, C2.
Now the key in
Fick's law is you're
going to hold these
concentrations
constant at the source,
at each of these points.
And so you can imagine
that it's going
to change as you
go down the hill,
and we frame this in
terms of Brownian motion.
We're able to understand
why concentration,
why diffusion happens down
a concentration gradient.
Now that flux, that flux.
Remember.
So J is an amount divided
by an area times time.
That's J. That's the flux
through the membrane,
and that is also
going to be constant.
Now, the d, what we assumed in
the d is that it's a constant.
So in the Fick's
first law problems,
we often assume d doesn't
depend on concentration.
So that means that if I'm over
here at a high concentration,
I'm over here at a low
concentration, well then--
by the way, this would be like--
oh.
Would you like some candy?
I would like some candy.
Thank you very much.
Do you mind if we walk
up and down the aisles?
No, not at all.
No.
Please do.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
This is just getting better.
I'm feeling less and less
like talking about Fick's law,
but here we are.
I'll go fast.
Now the thing is,
look, this is x.
By the way, I
really want to know
where they got the costumes
from, but this is x,
and this would be like
the concentration.
Now d could depend
on concentration.
By the way, it's actually
quite interesting.
It does have a small
dependence on concentration.
We often don't include it.
So this would be
like a straight line.
But if it did, if it did
depend on concentration,
then you might have a deviation.
You could have
something like this,
or you could have
something like that,
and you don't need to
have a straight line
to use Fick's law.
But in a lot of the
problems that we do,
we assume d is just
independent of concentration.
It's a constant.
So I'm adding more and
more carbon into iron.
Does the diffusion of the carbon
now depend on how much I added?
Well, yeah, it
might a little bit.
By the way, that doesn't
mean that it depends on time.
That's the distinction
I want to make.
So again, the problems
we do with Fick's law,
we'll assume d doesn't
depend on concentration.
We'll just assume
it's a constant,
but the main determining
factor to see
if it's a Fick's second law
or Fick's first law problem
isn't whether d changes
with concentration.
No.
It's whether there's
a time dependence.
a time dependence,
and that was the problem that
we left off on on Monday.
We say, well, you've got
to do this thing called
case-hardening to
a lot of materials.
You make the outside harder.
The inside assets a ductile,
otherwise, either it's
not strong enough,
or it's too ductile.
It just breaks down either
way, or it's too brittle.
So you want a case-harden, and
that was our Fick's second law
problem.
And again, I'm just going
to kind of set it up.
I'm not going to
go through it all.
But in the second law, what you
have is an ability now to look
at the time dependent.
So you can imagine if I have
position x and concentration C
and I start somewhere here,
so I have some source.
That's why we call it Cs.
So what did we do?
We took this piece of steel,
and we asked the question.
I'm case-hardening the steel,
so this is iron with carbon.
And I want to put carbon into it
but only up to a certain point
in a certain amount.
How do I know how long
to put it in the oven?
That's a Fick's
second law problem
because it's a
time-dependent process,
and I want to know
about concentrations
into the piece of iron,
into the piece of steel
as a function of time.
So you can answer questions like
this with Fick's second law.
So I had it at 0.25%
weight percent carbon,
and I carborize the surface.
I carborize only a
certain amount of it.
I case-harden it, how long
should you keep it in the oven.
And by the way, also
what should your carbon,
your concentration of
source be on the outside.
And all these things
kind of go in.
And so you could imagine
if the source is there
and I'm holding--
maybe I've got some
constant, C0, that's the 0.2.
That's the piece of
material I started with.
Well.
You can imagine at
t0, you've got this.
So this would be time equals t0.
And then as soon
as I expose this
to this higher
concentration of carbon,
you might have
something like this.
So now you've got t1, and now
I wait a little bit longer
and it's going to be able
to penetrate more in.
So the concentration
inside the material
changes as a function
of time and so forth.
That's what Fick's
second law tells us,
and the second law is
basically a heat equation,
which somebody noticed
after a lecture yesterday.
And you [? can ?]
let's see, dx squared.
So this is a partial
differential equation.
But solving it is just talking
to our mathematician friends,
and they come back and say
that's an error function.
And an error function
is just a function,
And It gives us a solution,
C, the concentration
at any position and at any time
minus the initial concentration
divided by this difference
in concentrations
between the source and the
initial is going to equal--
oh, boy.
You'd think I'd have learned.
36 lectures, and I still
worked my way into a corner.
I'm going to do the equals
this way 1 minus error
function of x over 2 root dt.
That is what you get when
you solve Fick's second law.
And now the error function
is just a function.
You don't need to worry
about the details of this.
You can think about it as
like any other function.
But one thing that I want to
share with you about the error
function is--
and this is something
that, yeah, you're
not going to need
it on the exam,
but you might need this in life.
You might get an error
function in life, in IRF.
And if you get into
IRF, I don't want
you to panic because
IRF is just a function,
and it just looks like this.
It just looks like it's a linear
plot roughly up to about 0.6.
This trick-- and then it
kind of goes up to 1--
it's just a function.
Is that 1?
Yeah.
And so if z is less than 0.6
then the error a function of z
is roughly z.
Talk about a valuable
thing to learn,
and that saves you a
lot of time, by the way.
But it's just a
function and it's
a solution to fix second long.
So again, this is how we
solve time dependent diffusion
problems.
And this is how you could
solve this one right here.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
not going to actually solve it.
I'm going to give you the
answer to that question.
So the time is seven hours.
That's the answer, and I'm
also going to leave you with--
oh, there's error
function tables.
Look at that, error
function tables,
and there's this
setup of the problem.
So I'm going to
leave you actually
with a sketch of the setup.
And again, this isn't something
we'll have on the exam,
but I want you to have this
kind of problem at your service.
So these are all
embedded in the question.
There is your CS.
There's your c naught.
At this distance, this is
what the question asked.
This is the
concentration we want.
We know when we look up
the diffusion of carbon,
we assume it's not dependent
on concentration, that D.
And so we just use a constant,
and then we plug it in,
and we get a time.
You better believe that
this is really important.
This is really,
really important.
This is how we make stuff.
This is how we make stuff
that we make our world out of.
So that's the
picture I showed you.
And this gets me now to
our last why this matters,
and I'm doing it on the backdrop
of this beautiful periodic
table.
So that's a lot of
energy, by the way.
First you had to make
these iron pipes,
and now you've got
to case-harden them
or maybe you've got to
put even more iron in.
Look at the other
900 C is really hot.
How much energy do we take
to make stuff as simple
as concrete?
It's just liquid stone.
Didn't you just grind some
stones down or something
and then pour it out?
Actually, if you think about
concrete and other materials
like steel, the use of
them is skyrocketing.
This is how much we're making.
So look at this, the
millions of tons.
Let's see.
There's steel, and
there's cement.
Look at that.
There's the world
population right there,
and this runs out in 2009,
2010, '11, but it's continuing.
It's continuing because it's
not just that the population is
growing, it's that the
places that the population is
growing the most are
also industrializing.
And that means building.
You go to some of these places
and there's a new building.
Literally every block, there's
a new building being built.
That takes this stuff.
That takes a lot
of ovens at a lot
of really high temperatures.
Just the cement
alone is accounting
for 7% of all CO2 emissions,
all CO2 emissions on the planet,
7% of that goes into simply
making this magic liquid stone,
this powder.
And at the core of it,
what is at the core of it?
It's chemistry.
It's clinker.
It's called the clinker.
What is a clinker?
It's this thing.
It's simply a calcium
silicate group.
Making that is what
takes all this energy.
It takes half of it at
least, making that right.
And as always, the
chemistry gives us
the chance to get out of our
constrained optimization.
And so you've got to make this
mixture of different types
of synthetic rock.
You've got to make mixtures
of alite and belite.
They have different names.
And you might be able to
make more belite, which
takes less energy.
You can cool your
oven down by 300 C
to make belite
compared to alite.
But then even though
it's structurally OK,
it takes 90 days to dry.
So you can't do that.
So you've got to spend the
300 extra Celsius to make
more alite.
Why It's in the chemistry.
It's in the chemistry.
And understanding,
what seems like
not a very interesting-- cement,
is it really that interesting?
You bet it is.
7% of all CO2 emissions is
just making this one material,
and we're making a lot of it.
We're making a lot of it.
There's a 164
tower in Dubai that
opened in 2010 that
took a billion kilograms
of this stuff.
Now, this makes a lot of CO2,
and I've talked about CO2
throughout the semester.
And so one thing I
wanted to leave you with
was also some things that
we're doing about it.
What do we do about CO2?
So how is carbon capture
and sequestration going?
Can we take it all out?
We put it in, can
we take it out?
And so I'll share
a couple of things.
So one of the problems
with CO2 capture
is that if you don't do it
right where you make it,
then you have to transport
it, and it turns out
that's actually really
hard to transport CO2.
And there's a lot
of problems that
have happened over the years.
In the '80s, there
was a leak that
killed thousands of people.
There have been
massive leaks in Canada
in transporting this material.
So transporting is
actually really hard to do.
There's metal pipe corrosion.
This is a great chemistry
problem unsolved.
And then the next part
of CO2 sequestration
is one is transporting
it that's challenging,
and the other is storing it.
What do you do with it?
Let's suppose we
could capture it.
Well, then what?
And there's ideas around this.
So you could pump it maybe
underground, geosequestration.
That's not a sure thing.
We don't know, we
don't understand
at those scales exactly how well
we can in case this material
and how long it lasts, so a
lot of questions with that.
There's a whole line of thinking
on putting it in the ocean.
Right?
Really?
So you want to fix the
CO2 problem by acidifying
the oceans even faster?
OK.
Interesting.
So transport and sequestration
is a big problem,
but what about technologies
where you simply sequester it
right there where you
make it, like clean coal.
You may have heard of
clean coal, so clean coal.
So I'm going to look at a
case study of a clean coal
project in the US.
In 2005, I got really excited
because eight companies joined,
and it was called Future Gen,
and the US government was going
to put a lot of money into it.
They were going to
capture 90% of the CO2.
You get a little
bit less efficiency.
Depending on how
you think about it,
it could be 30% less
efficiency, I mean, less power
out of the plant, but
you sequester the CO2.
And in 2009, construction
was planned in Illinois.
In 2010, it was canceled.
In 2010, it was restarted.
In 2012, there was all sorts
of discussions with the DOE
that agreed to pay $1.1 billion.
It was all located, and then
the companies dropped out
and the DOE canceled projects.
So that was 10 years.
10 years and $200 million of
taxpayer dollars and absolutely
nothing has come out of it.
So one of the things I want to
point out about this direction,
I'm not saying that it's
not a good direction
to keep pursuing.
But the timescales are long.
So we need to be able
to make decisions that
can cover longer timescales.
That's a huge part of
the challenge with this.
It's a policy challenge as
much as it is a technical one.
And tying this
back to the cement,
there is some really
interesting research
that's going on in
actually instead of--
OK, so you've got the CO2.
It comes out when you
make it because the ovens
and you're burning stuff, but
what if you could take that CO2
and just put it into
the thing you're making.
And by the way, if
what you're making
is a huge scale like
cement, then maybe you
can put a lot of it
in, and maybe that
could have a real global impact.
So there's a lot of interest
in substantial global carbon
uptake by cement carbonation.
So maybe you could get
some of it in the cement.
I like this paper.
I'm pointing it out
because they say that they
used Fick's diffusion law.
They modeled the carbon uptake
by applying Fick's diffusion
law.
Yeah.
It actually matters.
Right?
You can do this too now.
And just a few weeks ago
on CNN, this concrete, yes,
concrete is going high tech.
Why?
Because this company has
managed to figure out
how to put a bunch of CO2
into the concrete while
they make it, and it doesn't
change the mechanical integrity
of the concrete.
And it's in there.
It's actually in there.
This is all chemistry.
So this is, I think, another
very interesting direction
where technology can
play a vital role
in this particular
global challenge.
And now I'm putting
the chalk down,
and I come to the conclusion
I can't look there.
I'm going to get sad.
You're making me-- the
first thing about this
that I got to do is I
got to thank people.
First I got to
thank the concepts,
got to thank the material.
This is what we have
talked about all semester.
This is what we have learned.
This is underneath
the hood of so much,
and I hope that I've
conveyed that to you.
This is a starting
point for so much.
What have we learned?
Well, we've learned how
to go back and forth.
This is what I showed
you on day one.
And now what have we done?
We have filled this out.
We filled it out with
balancing reactions.
We filled it out with the
periodic table, that one.
We filled it out with electrons,
Bohr model, Schrodinger,
atomic orbitals, molecular
orbitals, ionic solids,
Lewis dots, VSEPR, Van der
Waals, London, H-bonds,
all sorts of inner
intermolecular forces,
metallic bonds, semiconductors,
bands, crystals, symmetry,
lattices, planes, x-rays,
x-ray diffraction, defects,
amorphous glassy materials,
reaction rates, rate laws,
diffusion, solubility,
Arrhenius, acids and bases,
polymers, and their properties.
That's you guys.
That's you guys that have
learned that material.
It blows me away.
That's a lot of stuff,
and we've learned it all,
and we've integrated
it into our lives.
But you couldn't have
learned any of this,
we couldn't have done any
of this without some people.
So now we thank the subjects.
We thank the people.
Laura, would you
stand up please?
Yeah.
Many of you have
interacted with Laura,
and you know and now sometimes
you might get a short answer.
You might get a
not a short answer.
But why is that?
It's because Laura cares
deeply, deeply about you all
and about your learning and
your experience in this class
and at MIT.
She cares deeply.
And that's the
kind of thing that
makes this class what it is.
We wouldn't have any
shot at it without Laura.
So Laura, thank you very much.
It's sort of like when
you drop your kids off,
if they go to sleep-away camp,
there's like the camp parent
who makes sure that your kids--
it's like they make
sure that your kids will
brush their teeth, get
to bed, have a blanket.
And they check in on
your kids all the time.
And I feel like we have
that for this class.
It's Laura.
So thank you, Laura.
But now the thing is
now the other, now,
I introduce these people to you.
Isaac, I still don't
have your picture.
But can the TAs please stand up?
Can the TAs stand up?
Come on.
Thank you.
I am so incredibly lucky
to have this quality
people, this quality of
staff, these kind, caring,
passionate, amazing people
as our TAs for this class.
And I am so lucky I get to
meet with them every week
to talk about you guys--
it's always good; don't worry.
it's always good-- and interact
even much more than that
about education, about
teaching, about how
to make this a fantastic
experience for all of you.
So thanks to the TAs.
And that's why I want the TAs
to throw the T-shirts out,
and we'll do that in a minute,
well, a couple minutes.
No.
One?
But see, it's the TAs that
have been here for you,
but it's also you all.
There is you.
It's you all that have
been here for each other.
And so I see it because
I talked to some of you.
I don't talk to all of you, but
I see the community that forms,
and I am very
appreciative of that,
and I'd like you to be
appreciative of that.
So let's thank each other
here for just a minute.
It's really pretty-- this is
actually getting me revved up
a little bit.
Now, I skipped over.
The goodie bags are
amazing, and so I'm
thankful to the goodie bags and
to the department, if anyone
is here from the department,
for helping us support
these goodie bags, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
That's good.
So I'm very grateful to that.
I'm grateful to all of you.
And last but not least,
I guess just last,
I am thankful to Harvard.
I was going to say
something else.
But anyway, I'm thankful
to all of these resources
that we have used.
And so I'm going to give
you some closing comments.
I started this semester
off in the first lecture,
and I asked you all a question.
And the question was,
why are you here?
And I said really, really,
really, why are you here.
Why did you come to MIT?
And I asked you,
did you come here
so you can just phone it in,
get a stamp in four years,
and go out?
Did you come here so
you can walk around
some place in privilege and
look down on other people?
That is not why you're here.
That is not why you came to MIT.
You came to MIT because
you know that this
is where we will make
the transition from being
able to answer any question to
knowing which question to ask.
That's the transition
from student to scholar.
And you know that you came here
because you have a passion,
and you want to come to a place
where you can take that passion
and you can try to solve
really hard problems together
to make the world
a better place.
Those are reasons
why you came here.
You came here because you
know that progress does not
happen because of success.
It doesn't.
It happens entirely
because of what
you choose to do with failure.
That's MIT, that's the MIT way,
and that's why you're here,
and I asked you to think about
that on the first lecture.
And then I gave you a
whole lot of examples
throughout the class.
I tried to connect our
learning and solid state
chemistry to global challenges,
to global challenges
that we face.
And I tried to do that.
So I had 36 opportunities.
There's many more, so I
had to pick and choose
carefully to try to give you a
sense of some of these things.
And the thing is about
these challenges, one I just
talked about in many others,
it's not that these are things
that we need to do soon.
There is an urgency of
now about these things.
There is an urgency of now.
There's no more time
to talk about it.
And so these challenges, it's
not like something happens over
here, happens over there.
These are planetary challenges.
These cover the whole thing.
So it's all on the table.
It's all on the line.
And by the way, if it's
a planetary challenge,
it means the
challenge doesn't care
if you're in a blue
State or a red State
or if you live in Europe
or Africa or here.
It doesn't care.
So we better figure out how to
get our act together and work
together to solve these
very hard problems.
And that's why you're here.
That's why you're here.
And so on the first
lecture, I asked
you to think about
why you're here,
and on this very
last lecture, I'm
asking you to think about what
you want to do about that.
What do you want
to do about that?
And there's a lot of
things you can do.
I don't mean that you have to
work on one of these things
we've talked about
in this class.
That's not what I mean.
I mean, think about what it
is that you really want to do
and how you want to do
it, and then go for it.
You might have figured that
out before you came here.
You may know-- gesundheit--
already way before you got here.
You may be figuring
it out right now.
You may have no clue what you
want to do when you graduate.
All of those are fine.
But what I want
to leave you with
is a framework and some
thinking that what can I
leave you with as a
suggestion, as a framework.
And it really comes down
to three ingredients,
three ingredients
that I'm asking
you to think about
when you go off
and do, when you leave here,
when you go off and do.
What are you going to do?
How are you going to frame this?
And so the first
ingredient is kindness.
Now OK.
Bear with me.
Because you're all thinking,
what is he talking about?
This is a chemistry class, and
you're talking about kindness.
But you see, the
thing is, I'm trying
to think about what is a
framework that if you follow it
you will do good.
You will help change this
world for the better, which
is what we do at MIT.
It's how we think.
And the thing is I don't
care if you define kindness
as love or as helping
someone or as community or as
on one of those dates when
the candle was in the room
and you did the calculation
and you saved the day
because you knew oxygen
was going to run out.
That's all kindness.
All of that is kindness.
But the thing is that if you
have kindness in what you do,
it's really hard to do bad.
Is that under the hood?
Is there an element of kindness?
You can't have too much of it.
We need that vector.
We need that vector
in this world.
So that's one ingredient,
and the second ingredient
is knowledge.
Now, what I mean by this is
acquisition of knowledge.
And we have done a lot of
that here in this class,
and you do a lot of
that at MIT, and we
celebrate these acquisitions.
What I'm asking you to
do is think about this
as you go forward.
How are you acquiring knowledge?
How are you learning?
That sounds cliche.
Always learn.
You guys have to
keep doing that.
You have to keep doing
that because, for you, it's
nourishment, and it's
another one of these vectors.
You can't do any
harm by learning.
You can only do good for
yourself and for everyone
that you care about.
So keep doing it.
The rate might change
of learning acquisition
as a reaction, the rate
constant might be lower.
We know places where
that's already the case.
And that's OK.
Maybe the order is
lower too down there,
but I think they probably
are learning something.
Keep that going.
And the last thing is passion.
And this involves your talents.
You all have talents already.
You all have them because
that's part of who you are
and why you're here.
Those are things that
you bring a passion to.
What are those talents?
Maybe some of them are
hidden, but work on them
and pursue them.
Do things that you
literally are so
excited about you
can't sleep sometimes
because of the excitement.
That's what I'm talking about.
Follow that.
Feed it.
And while you do, lose the fear.
Avoid greed, and
embrace challenge.
That's what MT is.
That's why we're here.
So I feel like these
three ingredients,
I've thought about this, and
I thought about these three
ingredients, and
I've thought about--
we have these already.
You all have these ingredients
because that is also MIT,
and you are here,
and you are MIT.
And so what I'm asking you
to do is to hold onto them
and keep thinking about them.
There's a lot of reasons
why I love to teach,
but one of the big ones is when
I think about the challenges
that I share with
you guys and I have
36 chances to look
up in the room
and I think about
those challenges
these ingredients
and I think about all
of you, I actually
feel like we have a shot.
I actually feel that.
And so with that, good
luck on the final,
and have a fantastic break.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
You guys are amazing.
Thank you all so much.
I'm going to have to
leave here, or I'm
going to get really emotional.
I've clearly got a lot
of other dance moves
the TAs have helped me,
so I can practice those.
Thank you so much.
That's just incredible.
You guys are all incredible,
and this has been incredible.
So we do have 10 minutes.
I'm going to leave.
So you guys can
fill evaluations out
without me being in the room.
And so you can say
whatever you want.
Again, don't let the free
T-shirts being thrown at you
influence your opinion
or the free candy.
But thanks, everyone,
for a fantastic semester.
Thank you.
Thanks.
That was amazing, you guys.